Bitte nicht, bitte nicht, kennt uns wahrscheinlich nur von Patreon. Ihr seid nur durch Patreon gebrowsed und habt uns dann gefunden. Mein Handy ist Schrott, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen. Ihr könnt uns gucken bei patreon.com slash das Podcast UFO, findet die ganzen Folgen auch als Video on demand. Genau, und Florentin, das Projekt hängt aber auch am seitenen Faden, weil Florent beigert hat sich sein Lade-Input zu reinigen. Dadurch wackelt alles und ja, das ist eine Frage der Zeit bis alles. Ich habe letztens tatsächlich mit meiner Ohrenkamera in den Ladeschlitz meines Handys hineingefilmt und habe nichts gefunden. Ich habe Schaltkreise gefunden, ich habe matrixhafte Dioden gefunden, an die ich mich gerne angeschlossen hätte, aber nicht konnte.
Und mein Handy ist sauber.
Dafür ist jetzt Ohrenschmalz unten in deiner Ladebuchse.
Gut, das kann natürlich sein.
Aber es ist ja immer noch der Traum des Menschen, sich direkt an die Technik anzuschliessen.
Sagst du, da muss eher der Mensch evolutionär noch nachhelfen oder siehst du, der Ball liegt auf der Spielfeldseite der Technik? Technik, Technik, wirklich? Mensch ist perfekt, Mensch ist fertig. Große Einschränkung, körperliche Gebrechen und Krankheiten. Rücken, der Rücken ist ein Riesenproblem. Namensnennung Rücken. Können wir nicht jetzt, wo die Savanne kaum noch eine Rolle spielt in unserer menschlichen Alltagssituation, können wir nicht zurück auf vier Beine? Sorry, ich werf's mal in den Raum. Kann der Mensch, der unter starken Rückenleiden leidet jeden Tag, nicht einfach sagen, ey, aufrecht gehen, das hat uns über, durch ein evolutionäres Tal geholfen, wir haben das Mammut bezwungen, wir haben die Dinosaurier bezwungen, der Säbelzahntiger ist raus, aber jetzt … Was dazu verhängnis wirkt? Rücken. Hätte man nicht gedacht, dass der Rücken später eine grössere willenrolle spielt als der säbelzahntiger und jetzt einfach wieder zurück auf viere ich pitsche lange schuhe ganz lange schuhe kann ja schick schick sein adidas nike rebook you name it lange lange schuhe die das schienbein schön einpacken hinten den fuß so als sozusagen so ein spannendes heck und vorne so spitz dran, damit wir uns erstmal über die Schuhe, die Schuhform und das ästhetische Bewusstsein, ist ja gelernt. Weitere Idee, in diese langen Schuhe baut man vorne noch Löcher ein, wo man die Hände reintun kann. So das Hände, dass du nicht, weil du willst ja keine Handschuhe tragen. Aber wie würden wir denn laufen? Würden wir kontrapunktuell laufen? Wir würden tatsächlich den Kontrapunkt wieder einführen. Es gibt jetzt verschiedene Tiere, die einen gehen ja zusammenführen. Ja, es ist kein Trab, das geht natürlich nicht. Genau, also wie gehen fährlich, das fährt und beides. Du musst natürlich dann die neue Gangart links, rechts, es müssen die Skifahren. Die krabbeln denn Babys? Krabbeln die kontrapunktuell? Tatsächlich sehr unterschiedlich. Oder gleich? Das ist ganz interessant, ich habe letztes ein Video gesehen von, wenn du Babys einfach machen lässt, dann kommen die nicht auf einen einheitlichen Krabbelstil hinaus. Und nicht auf eine einheitliche Sprache. Richtig, die machen, was sie fucking wollen. Und es gibt manche Babys, also stellst dir vor, du liegst auf dem Rücken, Hohlkreuz, stemmst dich mit dem Kopf vom Boden ab und rennst dann rückwärts, also auf dem Rücken. Manche Babys krabbeln so, andere springen wie ein Frosch nach vorne, immer so stückweise. Also es gibt unterschiedliche Methoden. Ist ganz interessant, dass es tatsächlich kein einheitliches Ideal des Krabbelns gibt, sondern jeder auf eigene Art krabbelt. Das heißt, würden wir die einfach machen lassen, kämen die vielleicht auch auf diese Krabbelperson, wo man einfach dann die Hände reintut. Problem, was ist sonst in diesen Schuhlöchern drin? Weil da regnet es ja rein. Ja, und Problem, Angst bei Babys. Weil wenn man im Wohnzimmer sitzt, hat das Kind zu Betten, zu Bette gebracht, zu Bette gelegt. Und dann guckt man sich unten noch einen Erwachsenenfilm an. Fickfilm an? Ich dachte ja so. Ach so. So ein Film, der abends läuft, der nicht für Kinder geeignet ist. Ach so, okay. Und dann kommt das Kind mit der neu erworbenen Krabbeltechnik, also rückwärts die Treppe hinunter und guckt dich dann so an.
Weil machst du instinktiven Exorzismus und dann verdammt Kind ausgetrieben.
Aber auch hier zum Thema Furcht, ganz spannend, habe ich auch eine Doku gesehen. Und zwar wurden Kinder entrissen von ihren Eltern, in einen wissenschaftlichen Raum gesperrt und dann kamen durch eine grosse Klappe auf der Decke Schlangen hinein, wurden Schlangen hineingeworfen. Okay. Stellt sich heraus, die Babys haben keine Angst vor Schlangen. Ah. Null. Die haben die Schlangen angefasst, auf dem Kopf. Aber vor Gras! Das meine ich doch noch, wenn man sie über langes, grosses Gras hält, machen die instinktiv die Beine hoch und wollen sie nicht im Grase verstecken. Ja, aber was denn, wenn nicht Schlangen ist denn da der Auslöser? Gute Frage. Und der Sadistenwissenschaftler meinte dann, Kinder schauen immer zu ihren Eltern und reagieren adäquat der Reaktion ihrer Eltern. Also wenn die Eltern, die hätten jetzt Angst vor der Schlange und dann, ah, fass das nicht an, Vorsicht, Vorsicht! Und die Kinder nehmen das auf und dann haben die Kinder auch Angst. Die Reaktion der Eltern. Genau, die schauen sich das ab. Wo er seinen Sohn, den Vater ganz nah an der offenen Tür vorbeibringt und dann die Hand gegenhaut und sagt, oh, oh, und es fängt an zu weinen, obwohl es gar nicht sich den Kopf vongehaut. Und da denke ich mir aber schon, warum haben wir denn dann überhaupt Angst vor Schlangen? Weil wenn die Babys, also es gibt anscheinend nicht diesen instinkthaften angst braucht einen ersten der angst hat vor schlangen und das wurde wirklich jetzt über tausende generationen weitergegeben es bräuchte eigentlich nur eine eine generation furchtlos sogar nur einen charismatischen menschen so dem du geneigt bist nachzuahmen wie derjenige lebt ich denke an einen Ryan Gosling. Ja. Wenn der in so einem Public Service Announcement einfach mal sagt, Leute, wir brauchen keine Angst haben vor Schlangen, hier ist ein Video, versteckte Kamera von mir, ich wusste nicht, dass da Schlangen sind, und er geht einfach durch den Raum, als wäre es nichts. Dann, dass wir als allgemeine Gesellschaft sagen ... Ich wusste nicht, dass da Schlangen sind. Wir haben erst den Prank mit ihm gemacht. Also, Ryan Gosling wird geprankt. Schlangenraum, Ryan Gosling geht durch den Raum, ohne zu wissen, dass der Schlang drin ist. Dann sagt der Host zum Beispiel, Guido Kanz, sagt dann Mr. Gosling, Mr. Gosling, in dem Raum, durch den sie gerade gegangen sind, man schlangen, er oder habe ich gar nicht gesehen. Und dann Luftballons und Konfetti und lautes Lachen. So, jetzt geht Ryan Gosling aber in sich und sagt, was ist da gerade geschehen? Genau, oh, vielleicht bräuchst du mich. Was ist da eigentlich gerade passiert in diesem Prank? Oder die Produktionsfirma, die dafür sorgen will, dass wir keine Angst mehr haben müssen vor Schlangen, prankt so lange charismatische Prominente, bis der oder die Erste keine Angst gezeigt hat. Aber Sie wissen ja gar nicht, dass Schlangen im Raum sind. Den Teil verstehe ich nicht. Wir müssen eine authentische Reaktion haben von einem Menschen, der keine Angst hat. Also dann, dass der dann rückwirkend sagt, Herr Gosling, Herr Gosling, in dem Raum, durch den Sie gerade gegangen sind, waren Schlangen, und er sagt, ist mir egal, ich habe eh keine Angst vor Schlangen. Genau, habe ich gesehen, ich habe keine Angst vor Schlangen und das zeigt man dann. Rückwirkend, dann hatte er keine Angst. Rückwirkend, dann hatte er keine Angst. Anfragen als Testimonial. Okay. Für weitere Fragen oder Ideen, Verbesserungsvorschläge, einfach zentralen at podcast-ufo.org. Gösser. Gösser. Gössse. Gut, besser, Gösse.
Ich habe eine neue Frage in der Kategorie, bin ich das Arschloch? Oh, okay. Und das geht, also das viele... Ich habe eine neue Antwort in der Kategorie, ja. Ja. Viele Dinge werden jetzt aufgegriffen, nämlich dein Bahnthema, das generelle Podcastthema Bahnreisen. und mein Thema, das mich umtreibt, ist, wie weit kann ich gehen, bin ich das Arschloch. Okay, es ist so, vom Podcast-Buffet hast du dir was von mehreren Tellern genommen, du hast einen gut gefüllten Teller. Ich möchte mit dir was diskutieren, und das muss jetzt in Ruhe und hinlänglich diskutiert werden, um das besser zu machen, weil da ist gerade ein Missstand. Das darf nicht sein. Und ich hasse dem. Ausgemerzt. Und jetzt bin ich zum Opfer dieses Missstands geworden und ich bin sauer. Weg damit. So, alles fängt an. Ich fahre inzwischen sehr viel Bahn. Ich komme ja auch häufig mal zu dir nach Hamburg und da habe ich jetzt viele Punkte gesammelt. Dadurch bin ich jetzt zum, habe ich einen Bahnbonusstatus erreicht. Ankomfort. So, ein Bahnbonusstatus, nämlich den Goldstatus. Vielen Dank, vielen Dank. Ihr könnt euch wieder setzen. Flontien, auch du kannst dich wieder setzen. Hup, hup. Flontien, setz dich wieder. Okay, setz mich wieder. Ich fahre so viel und dann holt man sich ab und zu Flex-Tickets, weil man nicht genau weiß, wann fährt man denn eigentlich los. Und bucht sich dementsprechend jetzt auch keine Sitzplätze mehr, weil es gibt ja immer die Bahnbonus-Sitzplätze. Manchmal kann man sich die auch gar nicht buchen. Häufig ist es mir gerade passiert, dass man sich die einfach schlicht nicht buchen konnte einen Sitzplatz. So, und jetzt hat die Bahn ja diese Bahnbonussitzplätze für Gold- und Platin-Status-Kunden. Und jetzt gibt es das Riesenproblem. Eigentlich ist es nie ein Problem, denn die sind immer frei. Wirklich, in den letzten 20 Bahnfahrten waren die immer frei und ich musste es nicht mit mir oder niemandem ausmachen, ich kann mich einfach da hinsetzen, da setzt sich auch keiner mehr hin, die sind nicht reserviert, du kannst dich einfach da hinsetzen und hast eine angenehme Bahnfahrt. Und jetzt kam, war es so, ich war eh schon super genervt von dieser Bahnfahrt, wahnsinnige Verspätungen. Ich war super krank, wollte auch nicht da rumhusten und hab mich selber nicht gemocht und wollte einfach ans Ziel kommen und es war zu warm, es war alles scheiße. Da soll das extra Sitze geben für Menschen, die sich selbst nicht mögen, die einfach sagen, ich will auch mir selber gerade nicht auf die Nerven gehen, ich will einfach isoliert in so einem eigenen Bällebad sein, in so einer großen Glaskugel. So, wir haben jetzt kurz ein Problem. Ich muss kurz was anderes ansprechen, und zwar dein Handy hat noch 12 Prozent. Ich beobachte das jetzt schon seit 20 Minuten und dein Handy hatte erst 19 Prozent. Ich habe mir immer noch kein neues Handy besorgt, ich habe immer noch das Ladekabelproblem. Ich meine, es hat jetzt 12 Prozent nur noch, obwohl es Stromversorgung hat. Weißt du, was ich meine? Ja. Es fricht gleich ab. Ich kann, Moment, haben wir wieder das Problem, dass das Ding nicht an ist wie ein Trottel. Nee, aber es ist Strom angeschlossen. Das heisst, es verbraucht mehr Strom, als es kriegt. Stell dir das mal vor. Du läufst auf so einem Laufband und du isst währenddessen, aber trotzdem verbrauchst du mehr Kraft, als du kriegst durchs essen ja genau das ist das ist doch in das ist gleich leer ja was soll man machen tun beobachten das problem ja okay und dann kam es bis kaum musste denn mein zug war kaputt blieb plötzlich in stuttgart stehen ging gar nichts mehr ich satte im dunklen Zug, wie alle, weil die das Licht ausgemacht haben, weil die neu starten wollten. Weil es nicht schon schrecklich genug war. Unglaublich lustig. Zug ist kaputt und die Situation zu klären, der Versuch war dann, den Zug auszumachen, wieder anzumachen. Und ich finde es total angsteinflössend, dass selbst so ein riesen technologisches Meisterwerk wie der ICE-4 einfachgemacht wird, angemacht wird und dann geht's und dann fühlt man sich ein bisschen unsicher, weil man denkt, okay, wenn alles so funktioniert, funktioniert es basically wie so ein schlechter Drucker, den ich zu Hause habe. Ich vertraue Dingen, die man ausmacht und wieder anmacht und dann funktionieren sie, weil wenn das die Fehleinfälligkeit ist, naja. Ja, ging nicht wieder an und dann musste der ganze Zug, der ganze Zug in den anderen ICE, der gerade nach München unterwegs war, umsteigen, sondern wurden zwei ICEs in einen gepresst und der musste dann nach München durchfahren. Ich komme in den Zug rein und alle diese Plätze waren belegt. So, jetzt sind die ja reserviert für Bahnbonuskundinnen. Und ich hasse das so doll, was jetzt alles passieren wird. Aber mir ist auch schon oft passiert, ich war auch mal schon mal kein Kunde, habe mich da hingesetzt, weil man die meiste Zeit auch einfach gut ersetzen kann. Wurde ich gefragt, sorry, bist du Bahnbonuskunde? Nein, ja okay, ich schon leider. Weil es sind ja manchmal auch Leute mit Bahncard Hunderts, die einfach immer einsteigen einfach und dann nicht zwangsäufig ein, die zahlen auch 7000 Euro im Jahr, die wollen dann vielleicht nicht mehr Sitzplatz fünf Euro dann obendrauf bezahlen, sind ja auch deren Plätze, ich finde, na komm mal gleich drauf. So, und dann war es voll. Und ich habe gedacht, okay, ich hatte Angst vor dem Moment, dass es jemals passiert. Du musst jetzt quasi, du siehst die Leute und jetzt musst du auswählen, erst mal könntest du dich auch entscheiden zu stehen oder du überlegst dir, wen von diesen Leuten lasse ich jetzt zwei Stunden lang nach München stehen. Ja, oder wer ist kein Bahnbonus Premium-Kunde? Erst mal so eine Gegenüberstellung, wo du sagst, wem werfe ich jetzt vor? Weil wenn du jetzt da bei diesen sechs Leuten sagst, tschüss, sind sie Bahn Premium-Kunde, sagen alle anderen, ah, warum, also du fragst die Person erst mal, warum haben sie jetzt gerade mich angesprochen? Genau. So, ich komme rein, ich gucke mich nach rechts um und meine Entscheidung steht fest, ich versuche es jetzt mal, jemand wird aufstehen und ich werde sitzen. Mir ging es auch nicht gut, ich weiß, es ist so ein bisschen gewollter Verteidigungsmechanismus jetzt. Du bist schon sehr unsympathisch in dem Szenario, da kommst du jetzt auch nicht mehr raus, glaube ich. Genau, muss ich nochmal durch jetzt. So, und dann war rechts ein sehr, sehr alter Mann. Augenscheinlich kein Bahnbonuskunde. Augenscheinlich. Er saß offensichtlich das erste Mal in seinem Leben in einem Zug. Weit aufgerissene Augen aus dem Fenster. Warum sind wir so schnell? Der war falsch. Der war da falsch, vermutlich sogar unterwegs zum falschen Ziel. Kannst du nicht ansprechen und aufstehen lassen? Vermutlich würde die Diskussion aus nichts führen, aber ich, auf gar keinen Fall. Links, altes Ehepaar, kannst du auch nicht ansprechen, wollte ich auch nicht. Davor, altes Ehepaar, kannst du nicht ansprechen. Dann, ein Florentin-Will-Eska-Typ, mit einer Switch in der Hand. Moment mal, du warst das? Ein Florentin-Will-Eska-Mensch, mit einer Nintendo Switch in der Hand. Ja. Habe ich angesprochen. Okay. Habe ich gesagt, sorry. Also dieser, der evolutionäre Blick des schwächsten Gliedes ist einfach komplett treffsicher. Auch in so einer Situation. Ich wollte auch einfach den jüngsten Menschen ansprechen, weil da tut es mir am wenigsten leid, dass der dann jetzt einfach den Schmerz ertragen muss. Ja. Sorry, sorry, bist du Bahnbonuskunde? Und er überlegt kurz und sagt ja. Und ich sag okay, du hast jetzt aber relativ lange überlegt. In Bruchstücken einer Sekunde muss ich überlegen, wie gehe ich jetzt mit dieser Lüge um? Und hat dann gesagt, kannst du mir das mal kurz zeigen, die Karte, sonst muss ich jetzt irgendwie jeden fragen. Und sorry. Und dann hat er hervorgeholt einen Ausweis von der Bahn. Er arbeitet bei der Bahn, er ist Bahnmitarbeiter. Ist er damit aber automatisch Bahnbonus, Premium, Platin. Macht ihn das nicht zum ehesten zu jemandem, der aufstehen müsste, die Diskussion auch machen. Der Kapitän verlässt als letzter das Schiff. Verstehe. So, muss der Kapitän, muss der Mitarbeitende jetzt nicht dafür leiden, dass die Kunden ein gutes Gefühl haben, weiß ich nicht. Das Ganze können wir jetzt mal ausklammern. Er hat mir das gezeigt, habe ich gesagt, okay, alles klar. Davor, jetzt war eine Frau, in Enddreissiger, Anfang Vierzigern ihres Lebens, habe ich angesprochen, habe gesagt, sorry, sorry, sorry. sind Sie bei einem Bonuskundin? Sie hat gesagt, nee, wieso? Da dachte ich mir, okay, da geht es jetzt rein, habe ich auf die Beschriftung gezeigt und gesagt, diese Sätze sind ja für bei einem Bonuskundin reserviert, ich bin einer, ich würde mich gerne, würde in Anspruch nehmen, mich hinsetzen. Dann hat sie gesagt, ist das jetzt ihr ernst? Und es ist genau das passiert, was ich dachte. In meiner naiven Hoffnung natürlich stehen die auf und sagen, ja, das ist halt wie das System ist, don't hate the play, I hate the game, ich steh auf und geh raus. Aber sie sagt, ist das ihr ernst? Der Satz, mit dem man jedes System einfach zerbrechen kann.
Zumindest moralisch zersprechen kann.
Da habe ich gesagt, ich mag das jetzt auch nicht, auch dass ich sie hier ansprechen muss und so, finde ich sehr unangenehm, es tut mir sehr leid, ich würde mich nur gerne hinsetzen.
Und der Herr spricht sein Urteil, Stefan.
Die Glocken von Köln.
Ja, und dann hat sie gesagt, nee, ich müsste dann stehen sonst und ich habe ja Anrechnung auf diesen Platz. Dann hat sie gesagt, oh mein Gott, ich mag das auch nicht. Ja, sicher. Und dann ist sie aufgestanden, super angepisst und hat sich die ganzen zwei Stunden von Stuttgart nach München neben mich gestellt. Gestellt. In Richtung meines Platzes stand sie da und starrt mich an, während ich sitze. So, aber das ist ihr gutes Recht. Das ist die einzige Verteidigungsmöglichkeit, die sie noch hat. Und ich dachte mir, ich privilegier das Arschloch, das Volk starrt mich an, mit strafendes Blickes gewürdigt, unangenehm. Und da hat sich ja manchmal auch so demonstrativ hingesetzt, in den Gang, natürlich um mich anzustanden, hat dann immer meinen Rucksack so weggetreten mit ihren Füssen, also es war mir nicht sehr unangenehm. Da dachte ich wiederum so, okay, es hat die richtige Person getroffen, weil es war sehr unangenehm. Okay. Und dann, das war das Beste, direkt ich setze mich hin und ich habe die guck start mich an mit finsteren blick und ich wollte nicht ich wollte dass der sitz nicht so bequem aussieht deswegen habe ich mich immer so nach vorne gebeugt ich habe jetzt nicht den ich nehme mich zurück mach den sitz zurück ja ja genau tupperdose auf ja schön musik an guck aus dem fernfenster Weinberge ziehen vorbei, ich selige, grosse Augen und dann fallen mir die Augen zu, weil ich auf Wolken liege. Nein, ich wollte so tun, ich habe viel gehustet, habe da so gesessen, weil ich dachte, es muss alles unbequem aussieht, damit sie jetzt auch nicht so viel Genugtuung bekommt in dieser schlechten Aktion, die ich gemacht habe. Was dann passiert war, mega geil. Dem älteren Herrn neben mir fällt plötzlich etwas runter, wo er nicht mehr drankommt, seine Brille. Und ich, Sankt Stefan, gehe sofort, gehe hin, mir fällt es auf, ich reiche sie ihm. Das heißt, sie merkt, ah, ich habe es in der Tat nicht mit einem Arschloch zu tun, jedenfalls nicht nur, sondern es ist schon ein aufmerksamer, in Anführungszeichen, netter Kerl, ahiße, vielleicht liegt es wie Unrecht. Fand ich sehr gut, dass das passiert ist. Es ist auch gut, wenn dem alten Herrn so der Geldbeutel runterfällt und er klappt so auf genau zwischen auf euch und man sieht genau keinen Bahnbonuskunde. Und du hebst es nur auf und gibst es zurück. Gibst es zurück. Dann super spannend, dann ist, wollte er aber seinen Koffer hochbekommen, es wurde immer voller im Zug, wollte ihn hochbekommen, das habe ich zu spät gemerkt, dann hat sie ihm geholfen, den Koffer hochzutragen.
Jetzt hatte sie, das war so ein ganz merkwürdiges Spiel von Hochstatus, wer ist hier gesellschaftlich, was ist das soziale Social Warrior Ranking und dann waren wir wieder irgendwie eben auf, super unangenehm. Aber ganz im Ernst, das ist schrecklich, dass das unter diesen unterfahrenden KundInnen ausgetragen werden muss. Dass man da alleine gelassen wird mit dieser Sache. Ich muss aber sagen, Wir sind bei 16 Prozent wieder. Okay, es geht aufwärts. Der Kurs steigt stark. Ich muss aber sagen, dass ich das vielleicht sogar noch unmoralischer finde, was du danach gemacht hast mit dem Sitzen, dass du dich als herzlich guter Mensch verkauft hast.
Vielleicht wäre es ja sogar moralischer gewesen, ihre Genugtuung zu befeuern in der Annahme, was für ein Arschloch, weil sie lebt ja besser, je schlechter du bist. Wenn sie im lebt, was für ein Arschloch, was für ein Arganter Wichser, was macht der hier? Das ist ja ihr einziges Rettungsboot, in dem sie gerade noch sitzt. Ihr Hass auf dich ist das, was sie am Leben hält.
In dem Moment, in dem du dich jetzt als Sankt Stephan gebierst und als Samariter und als Hüstelnder, als Opfer dich da siehst, nimmst du ihr ja diesen gerechtfertigten racheeifer den sie ja nur noch hat ich glaube ich hätte das genaue gegenteil gemacht ich hätte ihr genau diesen feind gegeben den sie gerade will damit sie sich an ihren hass klammern kann weil das ist alles was sie hat weil du bist ja doppelt egoistisch. Du bist doppelt egoistisch. Du willst nicht, du schmeißt sie raus und willst dich dann noch als guter Bürger sehen. Habe ich mir genau überlegt, was kriegt sie am ehesten, ich möchte ja auch, sie soll die besten zwei Stunden haben in der Bahn, wie es mir möglich ist, ihr zu geben, obwohl ich sitze, mit der Prämisse, ich sitze, sie steht. Wie hat sie die besten zwei Stunden? Kriegt sie die mit Hass besser rum? Ja, mit Hass. Ist deine Lösung? Meine Lösung war, sie kriegt die eher rum, wenn sie weiss, weil der Hass würde mir die Bahnfahrt zerstören. Ich habe daran gedacht, wie würde ich... Genau, aber das ist das Opfer, das du ihr zuliebe bringst. Dass sie ihren Hass ausleben darf, ist das Opfer, das du bringst, um ihr das Leben zu verbessern, wenn du die Rolle spielst, dein Axiom ist, dass Hass der bessere, die bessere Motivator ist und dementsprechend die besseren zwei Stunden Bahnfahrt von Stuttgart nach München, ja, ich glaube nicht, ich glaube, jeder kennt die Situation, Autofahren, irgendein Arschloch schneidet dich, du bist stocksauer, was für ein Wichser. Ampel, du fährst neben die Person und siehst, ah, ist ein Rentner. Und dann denkst du dir, ah, okay, du kannst deinen Hass nicht rauslassen. Dann geht's dir besser. Dir geht's nicht besser. Ich glaube, wenn da jetzt wirklich so ein aufgeblasener BMW-Fuzzi oder so sitzt, dann denkst du dir, ja, was für ein Arschloch, habe ich es ja gewusst, die Welt ist gerecht, du bist in deinem Weltbild gestärkt und der Hass löst sich ja nicht auf, du musst ihn ja runterschlucken. In dem Moment, in dem da irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ein Rentner mit Krückstock sitzt, musst du deinen Hass ja runterschlucken und kannst ihn nicht ausleben.
Da unterscheiden wir uns sehr. Bei mir ist es genau andersrum. Bei Rentnernn denke ich mir, ah okay, es ist ein Rentner, dem ist es aus Versehen passiert. Und da ist dann die überliegende Botschaft, die Welt ist gut, es gibt keine Arschlöcher. Sobald es aber in der Welt was Schlechtes gibt, habe ich die schlechtere Zeit. Dementsprechend, wenn sie merkt, da setze ich ein Arschloch hin, er macht dann den Rücksitz nach hinten, hat die beste Zeit. setzt sich ein arschloch hin er macht einen rücksitz nach hinten hat die beste zeit und ist ein arschloch der sein recht in anspruch genommen hat sie kriegt den hass dann gibt es das schlechte in der welt in meiner welt ist das für sie die schlechtere zeit wenn sie merkt ab da hat sich ein guter engelsgleicher sankt stefan ist englischen hingesetzt weil natürlich kann man das dann machen wenn wenn man das Recht hat, das System ist halt nun mal so gebaut, dass man sich da an diesen Platz nehmen kann.
Gut, dann muss ich jetzt halt leider so stehen. Die Welt ist trotzdem eine gute, die Bewohner sind trotzdem gut und halten zusammen. Ich glaube, dem Menschen ist wichtiger, Recht zu haben, als dass die Welt gut ist.
Okay, ja, spannend.
Sie will Recht haben. Und du kannst ja trotzdem die Prämisse haben, mir ist wichtiger, dass die Welt gut ist, aber ihr zu liebe spiele ich das Arschloch, das sie gerade braucht. Sie braucht gerade den Sündenbock, auf dem sie rumprügeln kann, sie braucht gerade den Bockssack, mehr als die heile Welt, also gebe ich ihr diesen Bockssack und bin das Arschloch, anstatt dass ich jetzt auch noch irgendwie meinen Asthma-Spray auspacke und anfange und dann kriegt sie Mitleid, weil dann stellt sie ihren Hass in Frage und denkt sich, jetzt war ich so ein Arschloch zu dem, oh Gott, guck dir die Beine an, der hat zwei gebrochene Beine und so und dann fühlt sie sich schlecht. Mir kam ja sogar in den Sinn, wäre es nicht besser, weil wie fühlen sich Menschen am besten und haben dann vielleicht schöne zwei Stunden stehend selbst, wenn sie denken, sie haben eine gute Tat vollbracht.
So, wäre es nicht meine Aufgabe jetzt, alles steht unter der Prämisse, ich will diesen Platz und ich will mich da draufsetzen. Und jetzt ist, das sollte man nicht machen, ich meine nur, das war mein Gedanke. Ich bin auch nicht stolz drauf. Mein Gedanke war, sollte ich mir nicht sozusagen meinen Goldstatus umbinden, mit so einem Schlüsselband, den so einlaminieren, so umhängen dann und ein bisschen bedürftig tun. Ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht gut. Ich meine, der Gedanke kam hier, ich bin nicht stolz drauf und sollte maximal bedürftig tun, vielleicht stottern, zumindest ein mentally challenged oder körperlich challenged, Eindruck machen. Ja, ich we weiß, es ist nicht politisch korrekt,
und das sollte man nicht machen, das ist ganz, ganz schlimm.
Aber diese Person, die dann aufstehen muss,
fühlt sich sehr gut und denkt dann, sie hat eine gute Tat vollbracht.
Ohne es zu wollen.
Weil sie hat ihr den Platz ja nicht gegeben,
weil sie diese Bedürftigkeit sozusagen, die helfen wollte.
Ich stottere, schau nicht in die Augen.
Es ist ja wie der Ryan Gosling, der erst im Nachhinein erfährt, dass er durch den Raum mit den Schlangen gegangen ist. Es ist ja kein echter Mut, wenn du erfährst, im Abteil davor waren Schlangen. Ich müsste jetzt in der Zukunft müsste ich diesen Schlüsselband umhaben mit diesem Ausweis. Sehe, ich gehe jetzt rein, mache ich mir den schnell um und dann stottere ich, vermeide Augenkontakt und ja, tue mentally challenged oder körperlich challenged. Ist eine Strategie, aber ich würde in die andere Richtung gehen. Wenn ich, ich würde diese Arschlochrolle annehmen, ich würde folgendes machen, ich würde so, Entschuldigung, kann ich mich hinsetzen, ja, ich weiß, ich bin Arschloch, setze mich hin und dann kriege ich einen Anruf. Ja, aber ich finde doch keinen neuen Job mehr. Was soll das heißen? Ich muss am Montag nicht mehr kommen. Aber wir haben doch jetzt das Projekt begonnen. Und dann durchweinen. Zwei Stunden lang durchrollen. So, weil sie denkt, ja, das hast du jetzt verdient. Das hast du verdient, du Arschloch. So, und dann ist sie glücklich, weil sie weiß, es gibt Arschlöcher, aber Karma gibt es nämlich auch. Es gibt auch Karma und du rufst an und sagst, ne, aber meinst du nicht, wir können es nochmal probieren, Schatz? Super. So, und dann, wie, aber was soll das denn heißen, es liegt nicht an mir. So, völlig, völlig zerstört, du musst die Rolle spielen, du musst dann halt zwei Stunden lang weinen. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel Tränenflüssigkeit du noch hast. Wie viel hast du an dem Tag schon geweint bis dahin?
Schon einiges.
Okay, erst da. Da muss man natürlich mit den Ressourcen ein bisschen aushalten. Aber das würde ich machen. Ich würde ihr nämlich die Figur geben, die sie braucht in dem Moment. Und ich habe nur gedacht, das ganze System ist völlig überholungsbedürftig und scheiße.
Ja, keine Struktur.
Das ist auch nicht meine Aufgabe.
Und jetzt wäre mein erster, ich finde diese, ich verstehe, warum es diese Plätze gibt.
Ich glaube, die muss es auch geben, weil es die Bahncard 100 gibt, alleine schon. Ich glaube, diese Plätze muss es geben, es ist noch nicht meine Aufgabe. Geht doch dann, und das ist ja auch, dann geht es ja Hand in Hand mit deiner Pflegte den Ruheabteil, die Ruhehygiene. Wäre es nicht die Aufgabe der eh schon überlasteten Bahnmitarbeiterinnen, einfach dann da durchzugehen. Die gerade händeringend versuchen, den Zug überhaupt am Laufen zu halten. Genau, dass die dann da durchgehen in dem überfüllten Zug und die Leute aufstehen lassen, die nicht Bahnbonusmitglieder sind. Ja, klar. Nein, ich glaube, also die Lösung ist glaube ich klar, jeder kriegt eine Reservierung, Punkt. Es gibt keine Entscheidung mehr. Ich finde, das ist die dümmste Entscheidung der Bahn, motiviert natürlich finanzielle Interessen, ist klar, das ist auch nachvollziehbar, aber trotzdem dumm, warum überhaupt das eine Entscheidung zu lassen? Du gehst auch nicht ins Kino und wirst gefragt, wollen sie eine Platzreservierung, ja oder nein? Nein, gibt es nicht, jeder hat einen Platz. Und du kannst dich ja trotzdem überall hinsetzen, nur wenn es dann Probleme gibt, dann ziehen beide ihr Ticket raus und sagen, das ist meine Reservierung. Ja, okay. Ach so, für jeden Zug am Tag Sitzplatz oder für einen? Dann gibt es keine Flex-Tickets mehr, dann gibt es keine Bahnkarton als mehr. Flex-Tickets ist tatsächlich ein gutes Argument, ja, ist ein Punkt, dass du dann nicht für alle eine Reservierung haben kannst. Gut, dann gibt es extra Plätze für Flex-Ticket-Kunden. Und da ja alle anderen haben ja Reservierungen, gibt es halt dann noch die Flex-Tickets-Plätze, wo man hinsitzt.
Ich musste denken an Stewie von Family Guy, da gab es nämlich die Folge, wo er im Flugzeug sitzt mit Ryan, Brian und das war haarscharf Stefan, da hättest du dich jetzt aber fast verplappert und eine Frau sagt, Entschuldigung, können wir die Plätze tauschen dann kann ich neben meinem mann sitzen und stewie sagt no your poor planning doesn't make this an emergency for me und ich habe genauso gedacht diese frau hat sich keinen sitzplatz reserviert, sie ist keine Bahnbonuskundin, sie hat sich darauf verlassen, einfach auf dem Platz zu sitzen, der nicht für sie reserviert war. Das habe ich mir so eingeredet als Mantra, um da überhaupt durchzukommen, menschlich mit mir leben zu können. Aber du hast dann auch keine schöne Zeit und sitzt da und wirst angestarrt. Genau, aber das ist der Preis dafür, dass du sitzt. Und das ist dann auch einfach moralische Gerechtigkeit.
Sie muss stehen, aber sie hat das Gefühl der Überlegenheit. Und somit ist es wieder fair.
Ihre Beine tun weh, aber dafür geht sie zufrieden ins Bett, weil sie den Hass rausgelassen hat.
Und du denkst jetzt immer noch über die Situation nach, aber du durftest sitzen. Das ist nun mal der Deal, den du eingehst. Wenn du dich auf dieses System berufst und das einklagst, das ist dann der Deal. Da musst du dann durch. Und deswegen ist es auch fair. Auf eine Art. Am Ende war es dann nicht so schlimm, sie hat dann rechtlich schnell einen Sitzplatz bekommen, weil bei der nächsten Situation ein paar ausgestiegen sind. Aber ich meine, nein, nein, nein, nein. Also das möchte ich nicht nochmal erleben. Ja, kann ich verstehen, kann ich absolut verstehen. Es ist leider einfach der absolute Albtraum weiterhin. Also Bahnbonussystem, oh Gott, oh Gott. Es ist hart. Es kennt auch niemand. Es weiß auch niemand von der Existenz, da steht es ja so klein dran. Ich weiß nicht, was denn die bessere Lösung wäre. Wir kommen ja auch nicht so richtig drauf. Aber das war für mich eine sehr, sehr schlimme Erfahrung. Ja, also Menschen aufzuzwingen, diesen Statusunterschied selber durchzusetzen, obwohl man ihnen nicht selber das System gebaut hat. Aber man muss sich da trotzdem rechtfinden, ist richtig uneingenehm. Andererseits setzen sich ja keine zweite Klasse Leute in die erste Klasse rein, weil der Schaffner würde sagen, tschüss, sie sind hier falsch, sie müssen die erste Klasse gehen. Diese Plätze sind ja nicht so. Da müsste man eigentlich, dann ist es eigentlich eine eigene Klasse, die ist ja nicht besser als eins oder zwei, aber es ist einfach eine eigene Klasse und dann müsste man, da müssten die kontrollierenden Personen daran vorbeilaufen und sagen, nee, sie sind hier falsch. Es ist leider genau wie beim Ruhrabteil schlicht und einfach ein Kommunikationsproblem. Wenn da ein riesiges Schild stünde, diese Plätze sind für Bahnbonuskunden, riesengroß, und dann setzt du dich hin und denkst, ah, ich bin kein Bahnbonuskunde, ich sitze hier auf einem heißen Stuhl, ich kann jede Sekunde wieder gehen. Und dann kommt jemand und sagt, jetzt ist es soweit, jetzt drücke ich den Knopf, jetzt müssen Sie gehen, dann sagt die Person, okay, ich gehe. Aber es ist immer so winzig und klein und Ruheabteil, so ganz winzig in ganz hellgrauer Font, das ist das grösste Problem, riesengroß, weil erste Klasse merkt jeder, weil es ist ein eigenes Abteil, merkst du sofort, das ist das grösste Problem, das ist einfach riesen Luftballons, Tröten, ganz, ganz deutlich, also macht die, macht, gibt eine andere Farbe den Sitzen, macht da ein riesiges Schild drüber, ein durchgehend laufender Jingle, ganz, ganz deutlich, damit die Leute das checken.
Und deswegen wieder die Lösung für mich, ich habe vor einer Zeit mal das Sedieren vorgeschlagen für Flugzeuge, dass man Leute, dass man Anästhesisten an Bord hat.
Genau.
Und Flughäfen sind nur noch so grosse Einschlafräume, wo man hingeht, setzen sich da alle super schick so im Kreis und dann kriegst du halt irgendeine Ampulle und bist so lange eingeschläfert, falls du es vorallt, bis so lange unter Anästhetikern wie der Flug geht. Genau, es gibt keine Sitze mehr im Flugzeug, weil man einfach mit grossen Gabeln, mit grossen Ladeln einfach reingeworfen wird.
Ja, passen mehr als ein Flieger.
Passen richtig viele rein, randvoll.
Ist ökologischer. Und dann wachst du in Dubai in einem Aufwachraum auf, kriegst nichts mit, hast perfekt geschlafen. Genau, du wachst auf, hast Erdnüsse im Mund, die wurden dir währenddessen reingesteckt und der Flug ist vorbei. Perfekt. Es gibt aber noch eine dritte Möglichkeit der Fortbewegung, das Autofahren.
Sorry, ich will nur kurz noch sagen, und deswegen hätte ich gerne so Pillen, die man sich reinschluckt, wo man dann vier Stunden lang sediert ist zum Beispiel, halt so lange wie die Bahnfahrt Köln-Hamburg dauert. Ich schmeiße mir diese Pille ein, bin vier Stunden raus und sitze da und kriege nichts mit. Das will ich doch eigentlich. Ja, ja. Und dann sitze ich da rum und dann muss ich mir auf und dann hat jemand zurecht gefragt,
was passiert, wenn der, also wenn der Zug dann zum Beispiel eine technische. da und kriege nichts mit. Das will ich doch eigentlich. Und dann sitze ich da rum und dann muss ich mir auf, und dann hat jemand
zurecht gefragt, was ist denn, wenn der
Zug dann zum Beispiel eine technische
Panne hat und man muss umsteigen oder so, dann sitze
ich da und wache an einem Ziel auf, wo ich gar nicht
ging, gehöre, an einem dunklen Zug.
Und deswegen muss ich mir dann natürlich, hier habe ich
so ein Schild um mich herum,
wo draufsteht, ich habe
Benzoclipol eingeworfen.
Und dann muss ich handschriftlich draufschreiben, ich wache auf um, handschriftlich, 18.04 Uhr. Richtig. Im Notfall will ich getragen werden. Genau, und dann gibt es so verschiedene Rollstühle und wenn der Zug dann stehen bleibt und dann müssen alle umsteigen, dann buche ich dann da mit, es kostet dann das Aufpreis natürlich, ich bin ein Benzoglypol-Kunde und dann muss man mich, dann kauft man den Service mit, man setzt mich auf den Rollstuhl und fährt mich in den anderen, dann kommt man am Bahnhof, wenn man dann rumsteht, ab und zu mal so vier so Rollstuhl vorbei mit so sedierten Leuten, die so haben es wirklich 18.09 Uhr so drauf. Ja, vor allem, du brauchst ja eigentlich gar keinen Sitz, du kannst dich ja eigentlich auch in so einem Schlafsack fledermausartig irgendwie an die Decke hängen, platzspanend, und dann kann man irgendwie dich wie so mit so einer langen Stange, also wackelnde Kons, wie so Leichensäcke, kann man die zwei Barmitarbeiter einfach die ganze Stange mit den ganzen Leuten da einfach von einem Zug in den anderen hängen und dann dotzen die auch die ganze Zeit zueinander, aber kriegen nichts mit. Nichts mit. Selbstsiedierung ist ohnehin Riesenthema. Hallo, ich bin Stefan, stehen Sie drauf, ich wache wieder auf um 18.04. Ich finde das so lustig und dann werde ich so getragen. Ich finde es eine gute Idee. Warum das nicht Usus ist, weiß ich auch nicht. Also dieses generelle Medikamentieren zu sagen, ich baller mich einfach weg für drei Stunden oder so. Ja, das sollte man auf gar keinen Fall machen im Strassenverkehr.
Im Strassenverkehr ist ohnehin gefährlich, aber es gibt weitere Gefahren, unter anderem eine Gefahr im Strassenverkehr, natürlich der Podcast.
Eine der grössten Gefahren im Strassenverkehr und natürlich, wir übernehmen Verantwortung.
Deswegen kommen wir jetzt zu unserer Kategorie.
Ra-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ding-e-ling-e-ling-e-ling-e-ling-die-das-Podcast-UFO-Verantwortung, Ortung, Ortung, Ortung, Ortung, Ortung, Ortung, Ortung, Wir wissen, wo ihr seid. Und zwar haben wir gesagt, ja, wir übernehmen natürlich gerne sämtliche Strafen, wenn Teil Schuld der Strafe bei dem Podcast UFO e.V. zu finden ist. Der Rechtsviel ist auch geschlossen. Nämlich, wenn der Täter zum Tatzeitpunkt den Podcast gehört hat und das nachweisen kann. Der Rechtsviel ist auch geschlossen. Wir haben eine Nachricht bekommen von JC. Moment, Moment, Moment. JC schreibt uns. JC oder JC? JC, JC. Klingt im Deutsch immer nicht so cool, Initialname. Der Jotze. Also Jotze, kann man auch sagen, Jotze ist dabei. Nee, das kann man nicht sagen. Jotze schickt uns jetzt Bilder von einem Blitzer. Wir sehen ihn hier auch erwischt. Ich liebe Blitzerfotos. Kann ich mal angucken? Ich liebe Blitzerfotos. Generell macht gerne den Instagram-Account Blitzerfotos auf.
ich will eigentlich den ganzen tag ich will eigentlich den ganzen tag in der badewanne liegen und mir blitzer fotos anschauen das ist eigentlich mein
mein lebensziel und jötze schreibt tach ich müsste noch einen strafzettel blitzer inrechen was was warum liest du das bericht vor weil er hat ick tach und ick hat er geschrieben deswegen auf dem foto ist eindeutig an meinem gesichtsausdruck zu erkennen dass ich gerade aufmerksam eurem wundervollen Podcast geloasht habe. Solltet dies wieder erwarten als BWs nicht ausreichen, müsstet ihr noch das Fahrzeug-Blackbox-Material auswerten, um eindeutige Video- und Soundaufzeichnungen liefern zu können. Jotze, das ist nicht nötig, alles Liebe und bleibt zahlungsfähig, in geistiger Verbundenheit euer Jotze. Und dann finde ich auch gut, er schreibt als PS, als Beweis, dass ich dringend einen Zuschuss nötig habe, anbei gratis noch ein weiterer Strafzettel aus dem Februar. Ich weise nicht, ob die mehreren Strafen und dein Gefängnisaufenthalt uns jetzt davon überzeugen sollen, dass wir dir Geld geben sollten. Ich finde aber, das reicht, mir reicht das, wenn das Foto hat mir gereicht als Beweis. Ja, genau, er wurde zweimal geblitzt, anscheinend hat er einmal den Podcast gehört, einmal nicht. Jetzt ist natürlich in der Schuldfrage, wenn jemand ein Verbrechen zweimal begeht und sich bei einem dann auf den Schuldentlastung Podcast-UFO beruht, würde ich als knallhatter Jurist sagen, hm, Manometer, ob das damit recht Ding zugeben. Begegnet es kurz mal unsere Rechtsabteilung, Achtung! Mein Name ist Christian Solmecke, Rechtsarbeiter und Partner bei WBS Legal in Köln und ich sage nein! Ja gut, wenn Solmecke sagt nein, dann ist es auch nein. Weil das Beweisfoto, dass du schon mal gewiss worden bist, ohne eine Zumischung von das Podcast-UFO, legt nahe, dass du immer bereit bist, das Recht zu überschreiten, beziehungsweise anfällig dafür bist, die Geschwindigkeit zu überschreiten, ob oder mit Podcast-UFO. Umwelteinwirkung Podcast UFO nicht tatdefinierend war, letzten Endes tatzwangsursächlich war und deswegen abgelehnt. So, dann kommen wir zu Christopher. Christopher hat leider eine ähnliche Situation ereilt. Er schreibt, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob eure Blitzeaktion noch läuft. Tut sie. Ich wurde in der Nacht vom 1. auf den 2. Juni geblitzt. Verjährt? Nein. Kommt wann, 2024 oder nicht? Oh, das schreibt er nicht. Ich habe einen Freund nach Hause gefahren, mit dem zusammen ich das Champions-League-Finale geschaut habe. Geht sich das zeitlich aus? Ja, glaub schon. Gut, im Auto haben wir die Folge Glocken in Dublin gehört. Moment, ah okay, ihr habt durch das. Passt das zeitlichmunder bin mir sicher, das war am 1. Juni, das Champions-League-Finale, dann unsere Folge Glocken in Dublin kam raus. Den Roman gibt es weiterhin zu kaufen, ich verstehe nicht, warum den niemand kauft. 1. Juni kam der raus. Okay, also sehr aktuell. So, wir haben die Folge Glocken in Dublin gehört. Ich bin in einer 30er-Zone 45 kmh gefahren. Dinger, das heißt, du bist 48 kmh, du bist 50 in der Dreissigerzone gefahren. Das wird mir ja teuer jetzt. Und musst 50 Euro Strafe zahlen. Es war ein stationärer Blitzer, an dem ich schon 100 Mal vorbeigefahren bin, aber in dem Moment war ich irgendwie abgelenkt.
Was haben wir uns dabei gedacht?
Ja, was haben wir uns bei der Folge Glock in Dublin gedacht, dass die so stark ablenkt?
Ich kann nicht mehr sagen, welche Stelle im Podcast abgespielt wurde, denn ich war sehr müde und stand auch etwas unter dem Einfluss eines Hash-Brownies, der erst nach vier Stunden angeschlagen hatte, just als wir mit dem Auto losgefahren sind. Ich denke, es kommt Alkohol und es ist fast noch schlimmer. Also ich bin ja wirklich sehr unerfahren, was Drogenkonsum angeht. Aber warum nimmt man etwas, was erst nach vier Stunden also wie muss man wie hart muss man sein Leben im Griff haben, um den Rausch vier Stunden also ich hab ja immer so das Klischee des Stoners ist ja so, lebt in den Tag hinein und ja passt schon, aber die Akribie, die nötig ist, um zu sagen in vier Stunden will ich den Effekt spüren, also esse ich jetzt, esse ich das, Hashbrownie? Also was ist denn, wie funktioniert das denn? Also erst mal muss ich sagen, grossen Respekt davor, für deine Ehrlichkeit. Also du willst ja, dass wir deinen Strafzettel bezahlen. Vielen Dank, dass du uns erwähnst, dass du dabei erwähnst, dass du sowohl unter dem Einfluss von Hashbrown standst, als auch, dass du, wie viel zu schnell du gefahren bist gut das erfahren müssen und auch dass du sehr müde warst ne ist auch ein grund vielleicht nicht zu fahren ich sehe hier viele faktoren ein faktor definitiv glocken in der blenden glaube ich faktor zwei glocken war hilarious ja absoluten also es war wirklich eine unfassbar gute folge zum gedanken schweifen Ja, völlig, völlig. Das darf auch so eine Rolle gespielt haben. Da werden Erektionen nicht unbeteiligt gewesen sein. Glocken in Dublin auf jeden Fall. Aber wir haben natürlich noch als weiteren Einfluss Müdigkeit, dann haben wir natürlich noch THC und wir haben natürlich auch noch den Rausch des Fussballs. Ich weiss nicht. Nach dem Fussballspiel dürft ihr fahren. Absolut, Wenn das nicht, dann kämen wir aber in heisse Bredouille. Ich würde sagen, wir wissen nicht, ich weiss nicht, wer Champions League-Finale gespielt hat. Dortmund gegen Real Madrid. So, ich weiss nicht, ob er ein Real Madrid oder ein Dortmund-Fan. Nein, wahrscheinlich Dortmund-Fan. Wir haben sogar sein Kennzeichen. Ah, okay. Was ist das? Ich weiss nicht, ob wir das jetzt hier nennen dürfen. Das Kennzeichen kannst du mir aber nennen. Ja, aber guck mal Stefan, wenn ich ein Wort sage, um es dir zu sagen, dann hört das automatisch auch jeder andere. Das kenne ich nicht. Wo ist das denn? Ah, okay, es ist nicht in der Nähe von Dortmund. Ist es in der Nähe von Madrid? Nee. Also können wir ihn denn geografisch... Dortmund ist näher, so wird es erlaubt zu sagen, Dortmund ist näher an Madrid als das Kennzeichen.
Dortmund ist näher an
Madrid. Und das Kennzeichen liegt eher nahe, dass er spricht. Sein Ort ist näher. Ein augenswinkender Tipp, du hättest die Mail, die Mail hättest du eher so vorlesen müssen wie die letzte.
Aha, aha, okay, gut, also können wir davon ausgehen, dass dieser junge Herr durchaus im Rausch eines Fussballsieges taumelnd diese Fahrt angetreten ist. Ich würde sagen, da lebt man nicht zugezogen, von daher würde ich sagen, nicht unbedingt Dortmund-Fan. Das ist ja ein Fussballspiel, was sehr viele Menschen interessiert, auch neutrale Beobachter. Aus Sicht der deutschen Brille würde ich natürlich sagen, sind die meisten eher für Dortmund gewesen. Aus Sicht der spanischen Brille? Würde ich sagen, eher aus Spanien gewesen, war Spanien gewesen. Gut. Von daher würde ich sagen, eher für Deutschland, also beduselt. Ne, traurig. Gut. Er schreibt weiter, leider kann ich nicht mit Gewissheit sagen, woher mein merkwürdiger Gesichtsausdruck stammt.
Podcast oder THC?
Ja, ähm, was sagt? Auf der gedachten Null sagen wir die Antwort, ja oder nein. Aha. Drei, zwei, eins, nein! Abgelehnt! Abgelehnt! So, also das war unsere Rubrik, die das Podcast-UFO Verantwortung, Ortung, Ortung, Ortung, Ortung. Ja, beide Fälle abgeschmettert, weil leider zu viele andere Einflüsse im Spiel waren. Leute, Entschuldigung, ihr müsst schon knallhart, juristisch, penibel, präzise beweisen, dass wir schuld sind. Ich sehe schon kommen, dass wir bald irgendwie so jemanden, der so 120 in der Spielstrasse gefahren sind, irgendwie so 100.000 Euro Schadensersatz oder so Körperverletzungen, die Entschädigung, die man dann zahlt. Ach so, Schmerzgeld. Schmerzgeld, genau, sowas dann bezahlen müssen. Und dann will ich jemanden unterstützen, der es nicht verdient hat. Da habe ich ein bisschen Angst vor. Aber wir lassen das mal. Der Rechtsweg ist ja ausgeschlossen. Du hast ja den ja ausgeschlossen. Und das stimmt sogar. Das benutzen wir sogar richtig jetzt, wie uns Herr Solmichel gezeigt hat. Inzwischen habe ich es nämlich verstanden. Du musst es dir nochmal ausserhalb der Aufnahme anhören, um es zu verstehen. Das verstehe ich schon. Wenn man so Gewinnspielen sozusagen keine Augenhöhe gibt, weil ihr in der Tat nur gewinnen könnt,
müssen wir den Rechtsweg ausschliessen, weil
sonst durch Klagen oder so Kram passieren
kann, den wir nicht mehr übersehen können.
Ihr könnt hier nur gewinnen.
Das ist meine Botschaft an euch, an alle
Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ja, cool.
Ja, damit tatsächlich geht kein Geld raus,
aber ihr könnt gerne einschicken,
falls wir tatsächlich der Schuld nachgewiesen
wurden, überheben wir das gerne. Ich gestehe gerne. Nimmst du mir die Beichte ab? Ja. Okay, ich habe eine Straftat begangen. Putin, vielen Dank für die Ehrlichkeit, ich nehme die Straftat ab. Wir sind ja nicht in einem religiösen Kosmos, also die wird ja durch nichts erlassen. Du kommst aber nicht in irgendeine Form von Himmel, Paradies,
Jungfrauen, sowas ist alles nicht jetzt Teil dessen. Ich kann dir nur helfen, dein Gewissen zu reinigen. Willkommen in der Kirche des Stephans. Seit deiner Heiligssprechung bist du irgendwie auch nicht mehr so warm. Ich hatte dich wärmer in Erinnerung als... So, deine Zeit tok es läuft auch die zeit des sankt steffern vergiss das nie okay willst du mir drohen oder willst du deine beise loswerden ich habe gestohlen gestohlen was kannst du dir sagen ich das weiss ich nicht es ist ein juristischer es ist eine Weisszone, es ist ganz klar. Ah, okay. Und zwar Tatort Bäckerei, genauer, etwas präziser, Hauptbahnhofsbäckerei, komm und gehen. Ich greife hinter die Theke, weil mein Zug gleich kommt. Du greifst hinter die Theke? Ich greife hinter die Theke, schnapp mir zwei Bagels, renne zum Glück. Was für eine Bäckerei ist das denn? Nein, nein, nein. Ich hätte so ein Backwerk. Nein, nein, nein, keine Angst. Also, ganz klassisch Theke, ist viel los, wirklich sehr, sehr viel los. Spricht auch nicht für dich, dass ich das gerade abgekauft habe, ehrlich gesagt. Aber gut. Hauptbahnhof ist wirklich wahnsinnig viel los und man geht hin und sagt, ja, ich hätte gern zwei Laugenbrezeln, Muffin und was auch immer, kriegt die Tüte, teilweise mehrere Tüten, eine Tüte Muffin, eine andere Tüte. Bewirft die Mitarbeiterin mit Geld? Haut einfach rein, sagt mein Zug fährt in 18 Sekunden, ich weiß, ich brauche 14 Sekunden für die Treppe, also wir müssen diese Transaktion in vier Sekunden beenden oder ich verpasse den Zug und komme nie nach Hause an. So, Karte, schnell, man macht so als gut gewollte Geste, mit der Karte einmal kurz aufs Gerät und rennt schon weg. Ob da irgendwas ankommt, weiß kein Mensch. So, also ich stehe da ungeduldig da und kriege meine beiden Tüten und schaue nach links und sehe, auf der Theke liegt noch eine Tüte. Herrenlos. Oder Damenlos. Man weiss es nicht. Und ich gucke so. Anscheinend hat jemand seine Tüte liegen gelassen, die lag auf der Theke, hat vielleicht, vielleicht mehrere Tüten waren im Spiel, hat aber eine Tüte zurückgelassen, die lag also da. Links von mir war niemand mehr, rechts der Rest der Schlange. Beobachte das ein paar Sekunden lang. Die junge Dame hat ihr Mentos vergessen. Ja, kann sein. Die junge Dame, nicht so schnell, ihr Mentos. An dieses Video muss ich eine Milliarde Mal am Tag denken. Ja. Und genau so jemanden bräuchte mich da jetzt. Der hätte röpft, die junge Dame hat ihr Weltmeisterbrötchen vergessen. Ich gucke ja auch, ich schaue. Denn nimmt die Verfolgung auf. Die junge Dame, nicht so schnell, ihr Weltmeisterbrötchen. Ich schaue natürlich nach links, guck, ist da jemand irgendwie, wetzt da jemand gerade los mit Tüten in der Hand, nichts. Es vergehen weitere zehn Sekunden Transaktionen abgeschlossen und jetzt bin ich selber im Begriff zu gehen und denke mir, diese Tüte, die wird ja... Es ist so krass, Menschen sind so unaufmerksam. Unglaublich. Keine Awareness im Alter. Nie im Leben würde mir das passieren. Nein, ganz im Gegenteil. Ich zähl noch mal nach. Ich habe drei Muffins bestellt. Wie viele habe ich bekommen? Nein, ich beobachte genau, ich will auch wissen, in welcher Tüte ist was. Und dann beobachte ich genau, wo hat sie jetzt was. Und neulich wurde mir eine Tüte zu wenig oben hingelegt, die andere Tüte lag noch unten. Ich habe gesagt, eine Tüte fehlt, und sie hat gesagt, oh, wollte ich nicht unterschlagen. Allein, um zu wissen, wie ich die Tüten im Rucksack stapeln muss, muss ich ja wissen, was wo drin ist. So, jetzt dachte ich mir, okay, was passiert mit so einer Tüte, weil, und ich möchte, Achtung, nur für euer Ehren und die Geschworenen, es war ein Hauptbahnhof. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass der Kunde oder die Kundin nicht mehr zurückkommt, um die Tüte zu holen, ist, würde ich sagen, nahe 100 Prozent. Weil die Person ist im Zug, ist am Gleis, ist da schon weg, kommt nicht mehr zurück, selbst wenn es auffällt. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es erst im Zug auffällt, nahe Osnabrück, Hagen, irgendwo in der Ecke, ist recht hoch. Also diese Tüte ist in meiner Welt herrenlos. Was passiert, wenn die einfach liegen bleibt? Wahrscheinlich, entweder würde es irgendwann auffallen, ah, da liegt noch was. Das ist meine Frage, als Bahnbonuskunde haben Bahnbonuskunden bei herrenlosen Brottüten das Vorrecht. Es lag nicht in dem Bereich, der gekennzeichnet war für Bahnbonuskunden, wo man sich einfach nehmen darf, was man will. So, jetzt sagte ich, okay, zweierlei, natürlich reizt mich die Straftat, bin ich ehrlich, aber mich reizt auch zu wissen, was ich denn überhaupt stehle. Also ich habe ja nicht nur den Diebstahl. Du hast nicht zuerst reingeguckt. Ich habe nicht angefasst. Wenn ich da reingucke, mache ich mich ja verdächtig. Ich muss ja meine einzige Chance. Selbstbewusst mitnehmen. Genau, reibungslos zu nehmen ist einfach meine Tüten. Ah, ich greife einfach alle Tüten, gehe weg. Genau. Zufall, bin nie wieder gesehen. War nie wieder gesehen, Phantom, niemand könnte mich beschreiben dort vor Ort.
Niemand. Also dachte ich mir,
Alter, das ist ja wirklich jetzt für mich eine unwiderstehliche
Situation. Einerseits Straftat,
andererseits, was habe ich am
Ende? Du klaust, du gehst nicht ins Museum
irgendwie Ocean's Eleven-mäßig lang angeplant,
sondern du klaust die Blackbox, du weißt
nicht was drin. Kann alles drin sein.
Weil das willst du ja noch viel mehr. Beim Bäcker, da könnte jetzt irgendwie so ein Kürbiskörnerbrot irgendwie was drin sein. Kann auch Muffin sein. Oder Kilo Koks. Ja, da kann alles drin sein. Nee, weil das so eine Geheimübergabe war. Ja, merkwürdige Muggelaktion kann auch sein, ja. Ich habe mich dann dazu entschieden, tatsächlich mein Gewissen herunterzuschlucken und zu stehlen. Ich bin zum Verbrecher geworden, zum Dieb, ich weiß nicht, ob technisch könnte es wäre mit sankt stefan und teufel will sankt teufel das gegenteil ja so sind so ein präschen da ja also sind der will sankt stefan und sünder will ja so und ich weiß gar nicht ob das wirklich hundertprozentig diebstahl war auch hier gerne christ Christian Solmecke, Rechtsanwalt und Partner bei WBS Legal in Köln, gerne hier mal aufgreifen. Eine Ware, die gekauft, bezahlt, aber dann liegen gelassen wurde, darf man diese einfach mitnehmen. Nee, ich glaube das Eigentum der Bäckerei wäre mein Tipp. Ja, aber die, mit dem, ja okay, klar, aber ich denke mir, jetzt mal unter Bürgerwissen, jetzt nicht Juristenwissen, aber Bürgerwissen, die Bäckerei wird das ja wegschmeissen.
Die wird das ja nicht nochmal wieder ins Regal legen, so auspacken und ins Regal legen.
Nö, aber so vielleicht.
Und deswegen war es für mich vogelfrei. Habe ich es mitgenommen? Ja, ich verstehe es auch. Und dann war natürlich der Moment, mein ganzer Körper kribbelt, erstmal in dem Moment, wo ich es packe, ich gehe, gehe um die Ecke, schaue mich um, keine Folgung, kein Blaulicht, es war keine Sting Operation, ich bin immer noch auf freiem Fuse.
Ich lege meinen Rucksack auf dem Boden, öffne ihn, verpacke erst mal meine eigenen Sachen, verpacke natürlich auch die dritte Tüte, ganz selbstverständlich.
Das wäre lustig, wenn du deinen Einkauf in der Heim liegen lassen.
Genau, es ist eine endlose Reihe bis heute, bis jetzt. Und in dem Moment, in dem ich sie einpacke, dachte ich mir, ich muss kurz gucken, ich ertrag das sonst nicht. Boah, was war's? Ich guck rein, Schokobrötchen. Hacking Jackpot! Jackpot! Auch was man sich nicht kaufen will. Nee, weil man vielleicht nicht so, ich würde es mir gerade nicht kaufen, weil ich unzufrieden bin mit meinem Körper, mag mich gerade nicht, ich gucke zu viele krassen Infoer dazu. Ich mag deinen Körper auch gerade nicht.
Was ich glaube, wenn wir jetzt bei dem Thema sind. Ja, genau. Deswegen hätte ich mir gerade kein Schokobrötchen gekauft, ich war doof. Und das ist natürlich das Beste, wenn man so eine ungesunde Leckerei, die sich darin findet, ist ja fantastisch. Mega gut. Ohne schlechtes Gewissen kann man es dann essen. Ja. Jetzt, klar, ich trage das Mahl des Sünders auf mir, aber ich genieße es. Oh Mann, ey, tut mir so leid. Für die Person, ja. Stell dir vor, das war die Frau, der ich den Sitzbass weggenommen habe. Oh ja, oh, das wäre so gut. Und sie sagt, was ist das für ein Ascher? Aber ich habe zum Glück noch ein Schokobrötchen im Rucksack. Er kommt mit dem Rucksack auf und denkt sich, ach Gott. Und das war für ihre todkranke Tochter, wie sie im Hospiz. Oh Mama, Mama, kannst du mir bitte ein Schokobrötchen von einem Hauptbahnhof, wo du weg willst, das ist das einzige, das ist das beste Schokobrötchen, das ich will. Und sie sagt so, es ist Make-A-Wish, du kannst dir alles wünschen. Das Schokobrötchen im Hauptbahnhof kann auch ich dir mitbringen. Du kannst Nicolas Cage wünschen, der ins Bett kommt und sagt, hier ist Johnny.
Oder was auch immer.
Naja, ich weiss es.
Mr Cage?
Verwechst du Jack Nicholson und Nicolas Cage auch.
Mr Cage? What?
Wir haben eine Anfrage bekommen aus Bochum.
I don't know the city. I don't even know the city anymore.
I don't even know the city.
Das ist eine Stadt in Deutschland.
Ein junges Mädchen, Manuela.
Sie hat als allerletzten Wunsch geäussert, dass Nicolas Cage an ihr Bett kommt und Here's Johnny sagt. What? That's not even my quote. Ich weiss, ich bin seit Jahren dein Agent, aber es ist ihr letzte Quote. It's fucking weird. Ich sollte von Anfang an wissen, dass du ein schlechter Agent mit deinem Deutschland und alles. Ich habe ihn so viele tolle Rollen. Mit deinem Deutschland und alles. Y'all mit deinem Deutschland. Nicholas, bitte, sei leise. Wir dürfen nicht gehört werden. Why? Du kannst wohl in die Ruheabteil.
Pst, pst.
Niklas, es ist Ihr letzter Wunsch. Würdest du es tun?
Hell yes.
Okay.
Und dann fährt er dahin, Anschlusszug, Verspätung, kommt er nicht zustande, letzter Wunsch, Schokobrötchen und die Frau vergisst es, ich nehme den Platz weg, furchtbar.
Entschuldigung, ich sehe, dass Sie gerade auf einem Bahnkomfortplatz sitzen. Ja. Ich weiss, es ist Nicolas Cage, aber... Nicolas Cage, I mean, what... Ja, aber wie viele Bahnbonus... What are you trying to say? Wie viele Bahnbonuskunde? I'm not a Bahnbonuskunde. Okay, weil diese Plätze hier... I'm not a Bahnbonuskunde. What are you trying to say? Are you serious? You wanna kick Nicolas Cage out? You wanna kick me, Nicolas Cage out? Ich will es nicht, aber die Plätze sind ... What's wrong with you all, talking to me in German, like that's my first language, it isn't! What's wrong with you all? Hier jetzt der ... Also, stellt euch eine gute Nicolas Cage-Impression vor.
Ja, das musst du nicht sagen, das tut mir alles schon seit Jahren bei dir.
Ich habe eine neue Phase und ich bin nicht stolz drauf, eSports.
Okay, wow.
Ganz kleine Phase, weil ich bin über Fussball, ich meine Fussballphase, EM läuft, yay, irgendwie drauf gekommen, mir sehr viel Fussball wieder zusammen zu gucken und war dann bei FIFA gelandet. Professionelles FIFA. Und du kannst einfach nicht genug von Fussball haben, dass während der laufenden UEFA Euro 2014 der Herren auch noch sagst, ich will auch noch die Pixelkicker haben. Exakt, genau. Und dann wollte ich mir nämlich, habe ich mir FIFA anguckt und dachte mir, wie fucking weird ist die Existenz von FIFA, ist so, so, so, so seltsam. Ich bin ja, da dachte ich mir, ich bin so ein Boomer, so ein altmodischer, das ist kein Sporttyp. Solche Gedanken kamen so ein bisschen in mir rein, in mir hoch. Da habe ich gefragt, warum? Weil es ist eine volle Daseinsberechtigung. Und nee, finde ich hat es nämlich nicht. Ich finde, Dota und deine ganzen Quatschspiele, die haben alle mega die Daseinsberechtigung als E-Sports.
Weil man Sachen macht, die man normal nicht machen kann. Feuerbälle, Drachen. Geile Spiele mit coolen Mechaniken und so, die haben Schauwert, die sind speziell, aber die einer sportart die es gibt online zwei jungs
am mit kontrollen controller in der hand zu zeigen nichts daran hat schauwert nichts daran
ist cooler ist auch fifa fifa profi-fussballer spielen fifa ja den würde ich lieber dabei
zugucken als rando guys mit dem red bull leipzig-Shirt spielen. Das wäre aber ein gutes Marketinggewinn. Wenn die kompletten Mannschaften davor eine Runde FIFA spielen, da müsste man viel Geld in die Hand nehmen, wahrscheinlich, aber das würde ich mir angucken. Ja, eher als dann so Randos, die dann gegeneinander spielen, in einem Sportart, die ich woanders sehen kann. Und das ist ja kein besserer Fussball, den die spielen. Da habe ich das nämlich geguckt und die sind ultralang, diese Spiele auch. Und es ist ein recht schlechter Fussball. Weil wenn beide sehr gute FIFA sind, was man ja ist auf diesem Level, entsteht nicht wie beim Fussball zwangsläufig ein spannenderes Spiel gefühlt, sondern das Spiel war recht schlecht. Habe ich vielleicht ein schlechtes erwischt, aber ich fand das so weird, diese ganze Existenz. Ich dachte mir, wenn Alien-Zivilisationen Aliens uns zugucken und dann sehen... Ja, die würden wir schlagen im Elfmeter schießen. Irre! Was für eine alberne Idee ist das denn, dass das professionalisiert wird. Ich finde es gut, dass sein Ausflug in E-Sport sofort mit Frustration und Wut beantwortet wird. Aber warum dann nicht Wii Sports?
So. Warum dann nicht eine Wii Sports Olympiade oder, weiß nicht, es gibt ja auch kein Formel-1-Simulationsspiel, was man lieber guckt, gibt es, weiß ich alles, aber gibt es ja nicht so professionell mit Geldvergaben wie wahrscheinlich FIFA, warum nicht, also es ist ja ähnlich. Ich habe tatsächlich auch mal eine Sendung gemacht mit einem professionellen FIFA-Spieler, aber der hat zu elft gespielt. Also wo jeder Spieler, das habe ich zumindest verstanden, vielleicht ist es auch Quatsch, aber dass wirklich jeder Spieler einen Munchkerl spielt im Game und dann rumläuft. Und das fand ich sogar noch alberner, ehrlich gesagt. Du hast ja mit einem nur gespielt. Nee, wir haben nicht FIFA gespielt, es war eine andere Sendung. Da war interessanterweise ein tatsächlicher Fußballprofi und ein FIFA-Profi, waren beide in meinem Team. Und es war so, den einen finde ich richtig cool, den Fußballprofi, weil ich Respekt habe, aber der andere, der war auch cool,
den fand ich auch super. Eher Unmut.
Aber das fand ich sogar noch alberner, dann zur Hälfte
zu spielen. Aber ich muss sagen, ich bin
also ich bin nicht so richtig im Fussball drin,
und wahrscheinlich ist Deutschland aktuell schon auch
egal, alles super
fun, aber manchmal
packt es mich dann doch, gerade so Spiele,
wo es einen ganz klaren Favoriten gibt,
die will ich dann doch sehen, so Bosnien-Herzegowina gegen Brasilien oder irgendwie sowas und ich sage, das will ich viel lieber sehen, weil ich will einfach entweder sehen, wie die komplett fertig gemacht werden und ab wann die, wenn es 18-0 steht, wann geben die auf oder der Underdog Story will ich sehen. Wie wir schon mal gesagt haben und auch andere Podcasts schon mal hatten, es sollte ein Jury-Draft-System geben.
Also wie Jury-Duty in den USA, wo du als Geschworener geholt wirst, Jury-Dienst, müsste es random, ganz willkürlich, werden aus dem Volk Leute gewählt, die dann die Fussballmannschaft bilden. Und zwar soll das im Anschluss an die Profi-WM der Herren, gibt es dann eine, oder Damen, gibt es dann eine Amateur-WM der Herren, um herauszufinden, was ist das wirklich Fussballbegnadete Land. Vor allem, es ist ja wirklich auch eine Schande, finde ich, dass die sportliche Mannschaftszusammenstellung ja so an der Geschichte hängt. Weil, klar, das sind die aktuellen Ländergrenzen, okay, aber das ist ja halt nur ein Jahr in der Menschheitsgeschichte, warum nicht sagen, Vintage-WM einfach mal von vor 200 Jahren, wie waren da die Grenzen, Heiliges Römisches Reich, Italien gewinnt alles, gegen das Osmanische Reich, ja genau, ja oder fucking Portugal, die halt ultra krass sind, aber heute halt ganz klein, irgendwie einfach nochmal neu mischen und dann, okay, da wo du geboren bist, in welchem Land lebt es, dass man einfach nochmal andere Sachen hat. Gut, vielleicht könnten sich die Leute nicht so mit den Mannschaften identifizieren, wenn das Osmanische Reich gegen das Heilige Römische Reich Deutsche Nation spielt, aber es wäre immer was Neues. Das Deutsche Nazireich sehr gut zum Beispiel, ja. Gegen die Alliierten wäre auch spannend, einfach so andere Schlachten nachspielen mit heutigen Fussballern. Genau, noch mal irgendwie komplett Mazedonien gegen die Perser oder irgendwie sowas. Ich finde, Achsenmächte gegen Alliierte, also ich möchte, nee, ich finde nur, es flattert vielleicht ein Brief ins Haus. Stefan, du wirst ausgewählt für die Amateur-WM. Genau, du bist Stürmer für Deutschland und dann muss ich mich vorbereiten und so. Das ist wie so Let's Dance. Man hat schon Zeit. Hat Zeit. Dettel die Soße greift dir schon unter die Arme auch ein bisschen. Ja, genau. Oder Julian Nagelsmann trainiert mich, bringt mir Taktiken bei, bin ich on, bin ich am Start und so, aber dann musst du halt nicht Profis, sondern Amateurmannschaften dazu bringen, die besten, und das ist ja so geil, weil du nullst ja alles, also es sind ja alle Länder haben ja den gleichen Chancen, aber eine willkürliche Auswahl des Landes. Wenn dann halt aus Versehen Cristiano Ronaldo gedraftet wird, ist halt dann so ein bisschen schwierig.
Nee, nee, das muss schon die Idee sein, kein Profifussballer.
Aber so sollte es ja auch eine Olympiade geben. Eine Amateur-Olympiade. Separat. Genau, separat. Ah fuck, jetzt muss ich ja für Deutschland einen Hochsprung vertreten. Wird nix. Ich wollte dann eben eines dieser Spiele sehen, ich weiß nicht genau, weil es war, ich glaube dieses Georgien oder irgendwie sowas, aber irgendeines dieser Spiele, wo... Georgien gegen Spanien vielleicht, so eins, wo ein klarer Favorit war und das war eines der Spiele, die nicht im Öffentlich-Rechtlichen übertragen wurden, schrecklich, sondern halt woanders, wo man ein Abo abschließen muss und das wollte ich nicht und dann habe ich halt natürlich geguckt, Kino T.O., Kino X, wo kann man diesen Stream illegal schauen und dann dachte ich mir einfach mal so, auf doof, guck mal auf YouTube live. Weil manchmal werden da auch so illegale Sachen übertragen.
Gestern erst lief dein Spiel auf YouTube komplett.
Und ich habe dann tatsächlich auf YouTube einen Stream gefunden, habe ihn angeklickt, habe ihn angeschaut, locker zwei, drei Minuten lang, bis ich gemerkt habe, das ist ein FIFA-Spiel. Da hat irgendjemand ein FIFA-Spiel als Livestream auf YouTube mit einem irreführenden Titel, einfach um Views abzugreifen und ich habe wirklich erbärmlich lang zugeschaut. Du bist mein Opa. Du bist mein Opa, dem wir ... Eigentlich, es ist an der Zeit, einzuschlafen. Es ist wahrscheinlich so PSG gegen Real Madrid oder ... Ich habe damals so einen Quatsch mit meinem Opa gemacht und dann hat er das geglaubt. Dann war er verwirrt, warum spielst dienstags um 15 Uhr Borussia Dortmund, war er irritiert, warum spielst du gegen die deutsche Nationalmannschaft, nichts tut, macht mehr Sinn, er hat trotzdem den Raum gedrückt. Ja. Scheiße ist das. Und du bist genau so. Ich bin genau so, ja. Scheiße. Ich bin genau so geworden. Ich meine, man muss sagen, die Grafik wird immer besser von diesen Spielen und ich schaue auch nicht oft Fussball.
Aber jetzt sehe ich wirklich, hä, warum sind die, warum jubeln die so komisch?
Wobei man muss sagen, die Grafiken nähern sich ja an, weil jetzt fangen die auch schon an, so teilweise so nahen von Fussballern mit einer krassen tiefen Unschärfe zu drehen.
und dann wird es wiederum, kriegt es so
ein Computerspiel-Look, weil die da auch
so tiefen Schärfe reinbringen,
Unschärfe reinbringen, damit das Publikum so ein bisschen
cooler und filmischer im Hintergrund
zu sehen ist, vielleicht auch einfach schlechter
zu sehen ist und das machen die
jetzt aber auch mit Kameran, weil es halt so ein bisschen so ein schönerer Kinolook ist. Und dann nähert sich das gerade wieder an. Von daher, das muss man ja schon geben, die Spiele werden ja immer besser. Ja, ja, klar. Aber offensichtlich wurde es abgehängt. Ich bin komplett, also das ist mein aktueller Stand von Fußball. Hast du das Spiel gestern gesehen? Ja, warum 18 zu 2? Genau, warum hat das Spiel sechs Minuten gedauert? Und warum stand einer der Spieler die ganze Zeit so direkt in der Bande drin, mit dem Bein durch die Bande? Wie geht das, was ist da los? Ja, und warum stand zwischendurch, wo das Spiel pausiert und dann stand das Startabbrechen der Aufstellung? auf jeden Fall, ich bin raus ein bisschen, aber ich freue mich für alle, die Spaß haben an diesem
illustren Sport. gepausiert und dann stand das Startabbrechen der Ausstellung auf jeden Fall, ich bin
raus ein bisschen, aber ich freue mich für alle, die Spaß
haben an diesem illustren Sport,
wo das Leder hin und her getreten
wird und ab und zu das Netz
berühren kann.
Vielen, vielen Dank für
eure Aufmerksamkeit, vielen Dank an dich, Florian
Will, fürs Sprechen. Vielen Dank
auch an dich fürs Zuhören. Schickt
uns gerne weiterhin eure Strafzettel, wir sind gerne bereit, Verantwortung zu übernehmen, wenn es denn
Verantwortung gibt. Ansonsten haut rein, habt eine schöne Woche, bis zum nächsten Mal.